earlier this year united airlines made
headlines signing a purchase agreement
with boom supersonic to buy 15 of their
future supersonic jet airliners in what
could be a bold return of supersonic
travel boom is looking to develop the
next generation of supersonic planes
building on the legacy of the iconic
concorde and attempting to address the
problems that led to the concorde's
final flight on october 24th 2006. the
concorde was a marvel of engineering
capable of flying from london to new
york in under three hours
so fast that passengers thanks to the
five-hour time zone difference had to
rewind their clocks two hours on arrival
arriving earlier than they left flying
across the atlantic in the concord was
super easy barely an inconvenience so
why did it stop being produced
the concorde failed for several reasons
the concorde had over 100 purchase
agreements with major airlines of the
day including united airlines but
soaring production costs forced everyone
but british airways and air france to
cancel their orders
then cramped and limited seating along
with rising fuel prices made turning a
profit for british airways and air
france difficult
causing ticket prices as high as eleven
thousand dollars why fly on the cramped
concord at that price when you could
purchase a first-class reclining seat
that only took four hours longer at a
fraction of the price
at that price the concorde was always
going to struggle to fill seats and that
just got harder after the unfortunate
air crash of air france 4560 in 2000
these economic problems were exacerbated
further by the extremely limited routes
available to the concord supersonic
travel was banned over the united states
and europe excluding the plane from some
of the world's most valuable airline
routes the plane's range was also
limited preventing it from capitalizing
on potentially lucrative trans-pacific
routes
in its 27 years of operation the
concorde's only regularly scheduled
routes were across the atlantic between
new york and london and paris
in order for the next generation of
supersonic planes to succeed they need
to address these problems and today
we're going to see how boom is looking
to prevail where concord couldn't
first off those pesky sonic booms
anything traveling over the speed of
sound is going to cause a sonic boom
that's just the fact of nature this
became a major issue in the 1960s when
hearing sonic booms was not a terribly
rare occurrence
with cold war fear at an all-time high
the air force regularly conducted
military drills near cities and in the
autumn of 1965
public acceptance of this nuisance was
becoming a serious political issue
forcing the us government to form the
national sonic boom evaluation office
this group then began taking
measurements of sonic booms with
different planes atmospheric conditions
and flight altitudes to gauge public
acceptance
they recorded boom signatures with
pressure gauges and created sonic boom
signatures here's three signatures one
for the f-104 one for the b-58 and one
for the xb70 we see a peak in pressure
caused by the sonic boom followed by a
drop in pressure and a final jump in
pressure again caused by the tail of the
aircraft what's interesting is that we
can see the signature for the xb70 is
longer than the others and that's
because the plane itself is longer the
studies uncovered a huge amount about
how supersonic waves travel through the
atmosphere and honestly the entire study
needs a video in itself because it's
incredibly complicated and rich in
history but for now the important thing
is that people absolutely hated these
sonic booms
the key word that emerged from the 6003
interviews conducted was startling and
people did not get used to them the
annoyance only got worse over time
many complained about physical damage to
their homes as the pressure waves could
physically rattle windows
nasa is planning to revisit these tests
in 2022 with the x-59 which has been
designed with decades of research to
minimize the pressure associated with
sonic booms with highly swept delta
wings a blunt duck build nose and a very
narrow fuselage that narrows over the
wings to conform to the area rule
with these design considerations the x59
is expected to have a boom with a
perceived decibel level of about 75
which the nasa team equates to the sound
of distant thunder
they plan to begin testing public
acceptance of this again in 2022
but critically overture boom's concept
commercial plane features few if any of
these distinctive low boom designs and
will likely have a boom just as loud as
the concord which registered at a
perceived decibel level of 105
that blunt nose creates drag and reduces
fuel efficiency while a narrowing
fuselage reduces space for passengers
sacrificing range and passenger capacity
for the sake of quieter sonic booms is
not an option for a commercial transport
plane and judging by the routes
advertised on boom's website this is a
problem they are perfectly aware of and
are instead focusing on increased range
and opening up those valuable
trans-pacific routes
so how are they going to manage that
thankfully the airline industry has been
heavily focused on increasing fuel
efficiency and range in the past five
decades since the concord was designed
and the team at boom will be able to
take advantage of many of these
advancements the concorde was primarily
constructed from aluminium overture will
be primarily constructed from carbon
fiber composites similar to the boeing
787 which allowed boeing to reduce
weight and drag while creating extremely
thin and perfectly sculpted wings
bending aluminium into the perfect shape
without creating stress concentrations
is difficult with composites we have
much more freedom in design carbon fiber
also comes with the advantage of lower
thermal expansion the aluminium
structure of the concorde expanded by
0.3 meters at cruise which had to be
accounted for with expansion joints in
the fuselage and hydraulic piping and
slack in the critical wiring
the overture for the most part shares a
very similar design to the concorde a
design that focused on minimizing
supersonic drag while being capable of
providing enough lift at low speed
flight for takeoffs and landings
let's compare the top view of both the
concorde and the overture the first
similarity we can immediately spot is
the ojival delta wings
this is a form of compound delta wing
where we have two sections to the wing
with the forward section having a higher
sweep angle than the rear section
the argival delta wing of the concord is
a variation of the compound delta with
an og curve connecting each section
going from concave to convex curves
smoothly this shape was used to optimize
for low speed subsonic flight and high
speed supersonic flight
creating a wing that can minimize drag
at supersonic speeds was vital
but these short wingspan wings create
issues when ticking off or landing as
the plane cannot generate enough lift at
slow speeds the argival delta wing of
the concorde helped alleviate this by
generating vortex lift where at high
angles of attack separated airflow would
roll over the wings to form two stable
cone-shaped vortices where air speeds
were high and air pressures were low
effectively creating lift
this is why we see the concorde landing
with its nose extremely high which would
have completely blinded the pilot's view
of the ground
the engineers of the concorde solved
this by creating a nose that could
actually angle downwards on command to
allow the pilots to see the runway when
landing the mechanics of this system of
course increased the weight of the plane
required routine maintenance increased
operating costs and the mechanism itself
would have increased the overall price
of the aircraft
the overture will not feature this droop
snoot but instead use a system of
cameras and screens to allow the pilots
to keep their eyes on the runway even
when their cockpit windows show nothing
but sky
the engineers at boom have a massive leg
up in engineering tools over their
counterparts at concord who would have
had to design the concorde with pencils
and paper while testing it in physical
wind tunnels
the computational tools we have today
are absolutely mind-blowingly advanced
just take a look at this simulation
performed by nasa supercomputers
modeling airflow around the landing gear
of a plane
this particular simulation was done to
investigate ways to improve noise
generated from the landing gear and we
can see these massive vortices rolling
off the landing gear doors telling us
that we can improve the noise generated
by focusing on airflow around these
doors
in the past engineers would have had to
use low resolution physical
visualization techniques to piece
together ways to reduce noise and create
model after model to test different
designs
today we can make the models in a
computer and test them on a computer
allowing incredibly fast turnover times
and vastly improved quantitative
measurements
tools like this will be used by boom to
land on the optimized airframe and
carbon composites will allow them to
manufacture those optimized shapes with
ease
on the surface the wings of the overture
are remarkably similar to the concords
by all accounts which makes sense they
worked very well but in order to
increase range they can't just be as
good they need to be better
it's clear that overture have made
efforts to make the wings thinner while
extending the delta wing further up the
aircraft seamlessly integrating into the
plane's sharp nose this will all help to
minimize wave drag wave drag occurs as
shock waves form over the plane these
shockwaves act like huge invisible air
bricks slowing down passing air
significantly and increasing drag
area ruling is one of the key methods to
reduce it
the area rule is a weirdly simple rule
in aerodynamics it tells us that the
ideal distribution of cross-sectional
area along the length of a supersonic
plane should look something like this
that includes the fuselage wings engines
and every other part of the plane
that's why we often see wasted fuselages
that narrow to compensate for the
increase in cross-sectional area caused
by the wings
planes never conform perfectly to the
area rule we need wings and engines to
fly and narrowing the fuselage over the
wings
isn't really an option for a commercial
airliner that needs to carry people
however carbon fiber composites do give
designers much more freedom in shaping
the aircraft to conform to the area rule
and overture will likely benefit from
these advances overture will benefit
from other advances in material science
that have enabled the creation of
incredibly efficient engines like the ge
and x
advances in aerodynamic modeling
metallurgy and 3d printing
have made today's jet engines vastly
more efficient than the engines of the
1960s and 70s but it's important to note
one major advantage that supersonic
planes cannot take advantage of
high bypass ratios
bypass ratios have continually grown
over the past five decades and this has
been one of the main if not the primary
driver for increased efficiency and
supersonic planes cannot take advantage
of it supersonic jet engines need to be
pure jets avoiding the high bypass
ratios of traditional airliners the
large diameter of these engines would
cause an immense amount of drag and the
large quantity of relatively slow moving
air coming from the bypass would
actually just slow down a supersonic jet
instead the engines of the concorde and
boom's test planes use pure jets with no
bypass
these engines have not benefited from
the past five decades of research that
high bypass ratio planes have and four
boom to succeed they are going to have
to develop an entirely new engine
boom's flight demonstrator the xb1 which
is set to begin testing in 2022 is using
the ge j85 an engine that has been in
use since the 1950s this simply will not
do for the final passenger aircraft and
this year boom announced a collaboration
with rolls-royce to develop a propulsion
system for use with their aircraft
engine development takes years if not
decades of development so it will be
interesting to see what rolls royce can
come up with before boom's advertised
first flight of 2026
it should be noted that the primary way
overture is going to reduce fuel
consumption is by slowing down overture
is aiming for a crew speed of 1.7 mach
whereas the concord cruised that too
even with all these potential fuel
saving technologies boom rather
confusingly advertises the range of the
overture at 7
86 kilometers just 500 kilometers over
concourse
one of the shortest routes over the
pacific is tokyo to seattle at
7651
i'm not sure whether boom is factoring
in the additional fuel capacity required
by regulators to ensure planes have
enough in reserve to deal with
emergencies but this is cutting things
extremely close for even the shortest
pacific routes and it most certainly is
not enough for the sydney to los angeles
flight advertised on boom's website
there is no doubt in my mind that we can
build a more efficient supersonic
passenger jet today but i am skeptical
we can build one that will succeed
economically
boom appears to be trying very hard to
obfuscate the limitations of supersonic
travel and are even advertising net zero
carbon nonsense about the plane being
able to use sustainable biofuel which is
not only not commercially available at
scale but is vastly more expensive than
kerosene
no flight operator is going to use
biofuel on a plane that will already be
struggling with ticket prices
the average price of a round-trip ticket
from london to new york was twelve
thousand dollars with concord it
exclusively catered to the ultra wealthy
who were happy to pay an insane premium
to save two hours of their day a narrow
market
a product most of us will only ever
consider as a once-in-a-lifetime novelty
and that's not a sustainable business
model for airlines
without a doubt boom can build a
prototype worthy of being the concord
successor that improves on all aspects
of supersonic passenger travel but
whether they can build it at an
affordable price point and get fuel
consumption down low enough for it to be
commercially viable is another challenge
entirely one i'm not confident they can
overcome
overcoming challenges to me is the joy
of engineering that dopamine rush of
solving a problem you've been working on
for days if not weeks
that feeling is what draws most
engineers into their career and perhaps
you have someone in your family that
gets that same joy
and brilliant premium may be the perfect
gift for the ambitious learner in your
life this holiday season whether you're
looking to learn something completely
new or trying to brush up on a few
topics the best way to learn is by doing
the work yourself and there's no better
place for that than brilliant brilliant
is an interactive stem learning platform
that helps you learn concepts by working
through them in visual hands-on ways
brilliant's extensive course catalog is
constantly expanding to include even
more lessons that help you learn in the
best way possible on brilliant it's not
about memorization or regurgitating
facts for a test you can just pick a
course you're interested in and get
started
feeling stuck or made a mistake you can
read the explanations to find out more
and learn at your own pace brilliant may
be the perfect gift for the curious nerd
in your life or maybe you just want to
gift it to yourself you can try
brilliant for free with the link in the
description or by clicking the button on
screen now and the first 200 people to
sign up will get 20 off brilliant
premium for a year of stem learning in
2022 or if you're looking for something
else to watch right now you could watch
our last video on the insane engineering
of the loudest plane ever made or you
could watch real science's latest video
on the questionable ethics of lab-grown
meat